[Music]
I want to get to this conspiracy we were
watching
uh an addition of planet Earth called
prehistoric Planet okay I'm watching and
I just can't help I'm looking at some of
these thinking
what
okay
what are the odds you sure okay and I'm
just looking at some of these like
supposed new dinosaurs
and I'm thinking
it's got to be big chicken nugget behind
this [__] what do you mean chicken
nugget companies are like we need new
shapes
I put out some [__] that's good we gotta
put out some that's good yeah
the Brontosaurus just is not selling
like it used to yeah we need some new
dino dunks and so I just start going
down a rabbit hole of like
these exist okay and that's our kind of
like I'm curious about people who don't
believe in dinosaurs you know so I just
kind of spiral down this you know
uh like who believes what on the surface
that I've scratched it seems that people
doubt uh the
the Integrity of the bones they're
digging up where would they come from
though I don't know
I haven't the government no isn't like
they could be made up or they're
exaggerating what they were
you know uh they doubt the
like even with the bones How Could You
effectively determine what they are or
what whatever
I I don't really understand the
like from a religious standpoint I
understand thinking this is [__]
God made everything like I understand in
being anti-dyno
if you're like no this deviates from
this book that I believe okay fine yeah
but I don't understand just generally
not believing in giant lizards yeah or
giant chickens
um that's what I'm saying there's like
stuff on the earth now that is just as
weird as dinosaurs are I I I I flirted
with
how many dinosaurs are real
then I landed on this video let me show
you the craziest [__] sentence I've
heard in my entire life
just search
chicken asaurus
that's second one
listen to this sentence he will not
believe what we're about to tell you
scientists have just created the very
first Dino chicken using chicken DNA
they've proven Health Solution works and
we might just see dinosaurs roam the
Earth again it's our one chance to live
out a real-life version of Jurassic Park
so join us as we learn how scientists
took chicken DNA and created the chicken
asaura
I put like I was thinking this sketch
where it's like me watching this video
and it just it just freezes on that
sentence
scientists took DNA and created the
first chicken asaurus and then it's just
me a guy like going through the world
repeating that to people yeah and it's
just like spreading like wildfire
just like at work like
you know scientists of DNA craze versus
chicken sword
like
oh
interesting and nobody asks what a
chicken asaurus is yeah and then it just
shows them later at parties and someone
like brings out just like yeah chicken
DNA it's like
you know they took
chicken DNA and create the first chicken
huh
how does it say
interesting all the way up to the news
close up on his phone yeah do you know
they took chicken DNA yeah yeah
in the group chat yeah someone responds
no way whoa that's sick no one ever
thesaurus exclamation mark
hell yeah
yo what's up guys I just found something
out interesting that's interesting today
just some tick tocker yeah scientists
took chicken DNA created the first
chicken asaurus
the world all the comments holy [__]
let's go let's go There's Hope
bro really said chicken asaurus
yeah
such an absurd sentence and it's I
watched this whole video
it's [__] [__] minutes it's really
stupid all they did was they took a
chicken and made it a chicken Source
what is a chicken asaurus it's a chicken
The Source oh
what do you mean it's the thing from the
video
oh it's the thing from the oh it's the
thing from my phone it's the thing from
my sketch that I was thinking about it's
a thing from my toy yeah it's a chicken
asaurus they just took a chicken and
made it into a chicken
oh wait this is a crazy frame no no let
this play let this play
I love this no just wait not this
included in their official research
protocol probably something about ethics
instead they noticed a difference this
Frame was so crazy to me the way these
women just look at this face is ready to
hatch chicks which differed considerably
from chicks who's just petting a hundred
baby chickens yeah
um
so they found yeah yeah
this doesn't even hard-boiled eggs
no this thing is like a big smoosher you
know so she's like petting them and then
she puts a lid on
[Laughter]
turns them on to it looks all dark it
turns them all into peeps
it's freezes them
scientists turned a bunch of chicks into
a chicken pancake
laughs
dead chicken of sources foreign
damn dude just pulls out a stop sign and
flattens them all
[Laughter]
damn is this our new thing yeah
stations now it's onto poultry
damn
there's a paint roller it was like going
through them
and it's like oh this one's bad
[Laughter]
throwing like the hundredth floor of a
building this one's bad yeah
now they've I guess they found out that
like uh
dinosaur beaks like a certain type of
dinosaur beak I'm gonna say the same
[__]
it was like a chicken
I guess they no I watched the whole
thing I guess what they found out I
found out is that scientists took
chicken DNA and made it into like a
chickensaurus yeah
they just um
yes they just like
what they do they genetically engineered
a chickenosaurus that's all they did
they took the DNA and made the chicken
asaurus smells like the beak has like a
different characteristic
and then they found out
basically what the characteristic was by
making a chicken asaurus okay what is
the characteristic well it's the
characteristic of a chicken asaurus what
is it though there's one from the video
yeah
it's the beak of the chicken asaurus
so is that what it looks like
no
you have to watch the video to see I
don't want to watch this [__] 10
minute video well you have to watch it
all the way through to understand what
it actually how many views
uh 2022
um sorry my Lasik was botched
how's this from year two dude somebody
somebody [__]
somebody posted a comment on my video
your eyes look weird no I'm talking
about my Lasik like I already had it so
I'm talking about the surgery and the
whole video was me like going into it
and then coming out after
so the process is this procedure had
been done and she left a comment that
was like you know some people have
complications from LASIK that leads them
to suicide
it's cool thanks
awesome thank you helpful thank you so
much helpful
and then she replied to that and said do
you know scientists you know scientists
took chicken DNA and created the
chickenosaurus created the first chicken
asaurus